it is this season heather the season of
ghosts the season of witches the seasons
of vampires and season of candy and that
too
you might just see all of that in the
magical forest
including bianca holmen she's not spooky
though only for today you get to see her
as the beautiful entity inside of
opportunity village's halloween event
we're so glad to have this back this
year bianca
yeah we definitely always gone last year
they're back so time to start carving
your pumpkins curl up and watch you know
scary movies like the nightmare before
christmas that's more of my speed i'm
not a michael myers kind of girl i don't
want to be surrounded by scary spirits
and ghosts and things like that but i
can do something easy kind of like
nightmare before christmas right
absolutely i'm the same exact way i mean
we do have our haunted houses here and
i'm like you can catch me at
cinderella's carriage i am not that
person
so taylor she's with opportunity so tell
us you know you all were gone last year
because the pandemic of course how did
that impact you all not having uh this a
magical fourth
yeah i mean so halloween here at the
forest you know it's one of our large
fundraisers that we host to support the
individuals who serve at opportunity
village and so not be able to be open
last year i mean just like everyone we
definitely felt the hurt and you know
not just the hurt that you know of the
of the money being raised but also the
spirit of everyone coming out and having
the community involvement but yes this
fundraiser here at opportunity village
definitely supports the individuals and
the programs and services for
individuals with disabilities so it's
definitely difficult it's good that all
the money donated and then raised here
at this fundraiser stays right here in
our valley to help again all the
programs that you all do so you know
we're in the magical forest there's
always something to look and peer around
and see here what else can people look
forward to when they come out
yeah one of the things that is different
from halloween to magical forest for me
personally is all the trick-or-treat
stations i mean see the kids come out
running around their costumes and it's
not just on the 31st you can have it all
month of october and that's probably my
favorite thing about halloween right
he's passing out the candy you see all
the kids in their costumes and so that's
really fun here at the forest um
yeah that's good good so of course kids
can still come out here get some candy
i'm gonna try to find some candy they
probably put it all away they probably
put all they knew i was coming and i
love candy corn so
taylor y'all got any candy for me i'm
sure we could find some okay
all right well again we got more
information coming up about what's
happening here at opportunity villages
magical forest and the halloween event
and of course all the events that are
happening across the valley on our
website 8newsnow.com i'm gonna send it
back to you guys in the studio candy
corn you can eat all that candy corn
yeah bianca i'm sure you could trick or
treat over at ov at a magical forest you
know just say trick-or-treat and see
what happens yeah yeah it might work
yeah i don't know anyone to answer but
or shake down your photographer chad he
might have fell in his pocket yeah
thanks bianca
there it is yeah
he's got it
yeah he's loaded already
we've got some other family-friendly
events for you the haunted harvest at
springs preserve there's live
entertainment trick-or-treating vendors
and boo town it's open next weekend and
halloween weekend tickets are nine
dollars for non-members and kids under
two are free reservations are required
so you do have to buy those tickets
online beforehand plenty of things going
on around the valley for halloween of
course and as bianca mentioned you can
find details on halloween and halloween
at eight newsnow dot com just search
halloween happenings at the website
you'll find the page with a ton of fun
lots of stuff to do yeah that time here